-The fifth Democratic debate
was last week,
and all the candidates
came out swinging.
You know I was gonna make
a joke about this,
but I don't think
it needs a joke.
I think it needs to be
slow-jammed.
You know what
I'm talking about, Tariq?
-Yeah, Jimmy.
I think you're saying you'd like
to slow-jam this news.
-That's right -- I want to
slow-jam the news,
and I'm not the only one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Crowd chants "Bernie!" ]
Hello.
I'm Senator Bernie Sanders.
And I, too, would like to
slow-jam this news.
-Hit me five times!
♪♪
[ Slow R&B music playing ]
-During last week's debate,
I went toe-to-toe
with my fellow Democrats
on the issues that matter most.
We need to defeat Trump,
the most dangerous president
in American history.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But we need to do more.
We can no longer tolerate
three people
owning more wealth than
the bottom half of America.
I have the experience to fight
for that bottom half
and to create an economy that
works for all of us,
not just those on top.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yeah.
Bernie Sanders is looking out
for your bottom half.
He knows it's been
neglected for too long.
Now he wants to pay it some
extra-special attention.
He's sick and tired of having
just a few people on top.
That's why Bernie's here to
spread the love.
-♪ Wanna spread
a little bit of love, y'all ♪
♪ 50 years of service,
giving people the power ♪
♪ He's heard it all, except
the words "please talk louder" ♪
-Now, tell me, "Woke Doc Brown,"
lately, this country's been
experimenting with
all the wrong positions.
So what's your plan to bring us
back to the future?
-Well, let's start here.
We need to enact
Medicare for all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We need to tackle the dangerous
threat of climate change.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we need to get
Big Money out of politics.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't have a super PAC.
Instead, I have
a grassroots campaign
with more individual
contributions than any candidate
in American history.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am proud of the donations
we receive, no matter how small.
-Mm-mm-mm!
You got to listen to my
bed-headed brougham.
He might not have a super PAC,
but he's packin'
something super.
He's all about
taking a firm stance
against corporations to give
the people what they desire.
-I know you're joking,
but it actually is quite sexy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Man, just the way you said that
has got me feelin' the "Bern."
And thanks to Medicare for all,
I can get it
checked out by my doctor,
'cause this hunka-hunka
Bernie love --
well, he wants to take care
of all of our bodies.
-♪ Bernie loves
your body, baby ♪
♪ He'll bring Medicare
to all consumers ♪
♪ And if you can't dig that,
then, okay, Boomer ♪
-Now, Senator, I was hoping
you could take a minute
and talk Bernie to me.
We all know you've got
a huge heart.
[ Music stops ]
-No, no.
It's a normal-sized heart.
It's a completely normal,
completely fine heart.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But continue.
[ Music continues ]
-Well, now that you bring it up,
what do you say to people
who think "The Sandman" is
too...mature to be president?
-Well, to those people, I'd say
that I'm feeling
strong, energetic,
and more ready than ever
to fight for
the American people.
-Hold up.
[ Music stops ]
So what you're saying is...
♪ I do my hair toss,
check my nails ♪
♪ Bernie, how you feelin'? ♪
♪ Hair toss,
check my nails ♪
♪ Bernie, how you feelin'? ♪
-Feelin' good as hell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Slow R&B music playing ]
-Alright.
One last question before we
wham, bam, thank you, Sand,
this interview.
I made a lot of jokes
about you in the past
and I even do
a Bernie impression
that some say is pretty good.
But I was thinking,
now that you're here,
do you want to do
a Jimmy impression?
-Ha ha!
-Are you gonna do
an impression of me?
-Jimmy, that was
my impression of you.
-♪ Jimmy's got
a third-degree burn ♪
-We must choose a leader
who fights for what's fair.
-Who cares more about
the people and less about hair.
-♪ Cares less about hair ♪
♪ Listen ♪
♪ Our battle's uphill ♪
♪ We cannot stand still ♪
♪ We'll write our new page like
we wrote the damn bill ♪
♪ It starts with a Bern,
then a fire breaks loose ♪
-And that is how
we slow-jam the news.
-Oh, yeah!
-Give it up for
Senator Bernie Sanders!